it's time for a scene and unseen segment
where we expose the cultural stories of
the day and for that we turn a Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo all right
Raymond you've discovered some steamy
video that casts new light on some of
the drama the ousting of Kevin McCarthy
what is going on Laura during Matt Gates
speech before the vote note the way
squad leader ilhan Omar eyes gates up
this could be an audition for the Fatal
Attraction reboot watch
[Music]
okay that could be one of the funniest
things that I've ever seen maybe she
just has chapped lips because I get
those well now look let me tell you
about this scene that you just saw these
two are like Sweeney Todd okay you've
got a couple that is locked in a Revenge
cult they want to take everybody out
here's why ilhan Omar I had forgotten
Kevin McCarthy removed Omar from that
from the house Foreign Relations
Committee because of her Israeli
comments and at the same time your your
guest yesterday Matt Gates he's under an
Ethics investigation I pulled the
complaint they're investigating him for
sexual misconduct misusing State IDs and
allegedly accepting a bribe and
transferring campaign funds to personal
things
it is still going on and he resents
McCarthy for not shutting so both of
them had a you're saying both of them
had personal she says that's not the
case
aggressive caucus Lord that's a hundred
members that went with them that's how
they got you heard of Friends with
Benefits this is friends with a majority
there's an retaliation for their role
and
Al karthi this
Pro tem through Pelosi and Stanley Hoyer
out of their fancy offices on Capitol uh
hill now they got the eviction notices
apparently last night yes and axios is
now reporting you will love this guess
who's moving into Nancy Pelosi's secret
Hideaway office Kevin McCarthy turnabout
is fair play look when you go after the
dawn the family is going to come after
you that's what's Happening Here do you
find it at all ironic Laura that the
gates mates along with every Democrat
voted unanimously to oust Kevin McCarthy
as speaker but no one has thought to
question Joe Biden's ability to lead his
office this was the president today at a
student debt event
you can sign up for the save plan at
studentaid.gov save
studentaid.gov student aid desk
studentaid.gov save how about Elder Aid
slash who will run.gov I mean this is
the most ridiculous thing I hope I've
fallen and I can't get it but McCarthy's
the one they throw out this is just it
it boggles the mind when the Republicans
are winning in the polls I think he just
went into REM cycle there don't you
think now the dysfunction at this uh the
White House Raymond seems to be
spreading though because we're now
learning that the first dog Commander
has claimed yet another victim yes the
12th victim Lauren we are doing yeah
12th night 12 victim we're already we
already knew Commander Biden was not
exactly a sweet lap dog we now have
exclusive video of one of Commander's
interactions with Secret Service agents
are you sure this dog here can track
down drugs yeah just give him a command
he'll jump to it hey pup
now Commander has adjusted his dining
preferences moving on from Secret
Service agents to the White House
groundskeeper this is Dale Haney this
poor guy he's been working at the White
House for 50 years walking the first
dogs going back to Nixon how is this
allowed you know apparently new shots of
Commander biting the poor man yes and
Laura just for the record Bo Obama that
dog didn't bite anybody the the White
House keeps saying it's the stress
they're stressing over this thing
they're blaming in the mega manga people
but they're they're blaming the the
solemn aspect of the Secret Service
agents now you've got the sweet
groundskeeper the guy's been around for
50 years tending roses and the dog
literally is biting his arm don't we
sense the two tears of Justice even
apply to the canine perpetrators right
any dog in DC that bites one time has to
be quarantined for 10 days you got to
get all the shots you get a warning that
dog bites twice major Biden was sent to
Delaware it's living with some
undisclosed family so this dog needs to
build the same place Raymond
um I got a little present here your
brand new book just out today it is and
it looks incredible it's another
children's book from your um turnabout
tale series The Magnificent Mischief of
tedling and there is a Fox Nation
special or it's the hidden story of a
beloved holiday tradition and the first
forgotten son who taught his father
Abraham Lincoln a lesson in mercy and
forgiveness that we need right now more
than ever spoiler alert this is the
reason we have an annual turkey pardon
at the White House ah you hitting the
road are we going I am I am I'm going is
there a day when you're not promoting
something well we'll see this Flag Day
is coming up this weekend
I'm in New Orleans Orlando the villages
in Jacksonville and next weekend
Nashville details Raymond all right
Raymond congrats on the book and um are
you coming any of the
oh I get out of it well you can sign
your name next time okay I'll cut you in
on the series
only if Commander could be ours and
Commander and I'm going to gift you
commanders fantastic give you my
security dog Raymond thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else